mais d'abord donc le bilan du ministre
de la justice eric dupond moretti a
délaissé sa robe d'avocat en juillet
2020 pour un marocain au gouvernement
post prestigieux est entrée dans une
nouvelle arène celle de la politique
comme hier devant le sénat jérémy
heinzmann
ce mardi en plein examen du projet de
loi sur la confiance dans la justice
philippe bas interpelle le garde des
sceaux ils lui reprochent une sous
consommation des crédits alloués à la
justice et un nombre de places de prison
inférieures aux 15000 promise au début
du quinquennat je suis ulcéré qu on
prétendre qu'on puisse oser prétendre
que cet engagement est tenu il faut
regarder quel aura été est
respectivement l'effort réel en faveur
de la justice et je vous le dis le
compte n'y est pas piqué au vif eric
dupond-moretti avance lui une
augmentation du nombre de magistrats et
défend son bilan ce que nous avons fait
pardon mais c'est vous qui avez donné
cette tournure politicienne vous ne
l'avez pas fait souffrez que je vous
réponde je vais vous répondre parce que
c'est insupportable
la critique pour la critique vous
voudriez qu'ici je vienne à canossa la
tête baissée pour dire on n'a rien
offert mais c'est une plaisanterie je
peux demander à monsieur le garde des
sceaux et rennes nos collègues sénateurs
de bien vouloir baisser d'un ton un
accrochage qui n'est pas propre à la
droite sénatoriale à gauche aussi
l'action du ministre de la justice nous
mais en juillet 2020 déçoit nous avons
l'impression que le garde des sceaux a
une conception hémiplégique de la
justice c'est à dire qu'il ne
s'intéresse qu'à la justice pénale le
contentieux pénal ce sont 8000 décision
rendue chaque année en france quand pour
le contentieux civil ce sont deux
millions deux cent mille décisions qui
sont rendus chaque année le temps vous
êtes garde des sceaux vous avez la
responsabilité des traités à la justice
dans son ensemble de leur côté les
marcheurs assure que le garde des sceaux
a déjà fait bouger les lignes avec une
augmentation historique du budget de la
justice
un pacte il il percute dans la
perception des français qui savent qu'il
est proche du monde des tribunaux qu'il
est proche des gens qui vont dans la
justice et qui comprenne qu'il les
défend si
dupont moretti n'étaient pas en train de
progresser et le faire changer les
choses il serait peut-être un peu moins
nerveux nos amis et le ministre entend
bien occuper le terrain d'ici la fin du
quinquennat avec notamment les états
généraux de la justice prévues cet
automne et on passe au crible le bilan
du ministre dupont moretti avec mes
invités katia dubreuil bonsoir êtes
présidente du syndicat de la
magistrature m basile ader bonsoir ça
bien mieux vaut aussi avocat associé du
cabinet august debouzy ancien vice
bâtonnier de paris stéphane le rudulier
bonsoir ne soit un sénateur et l'ère des
bouches du rhône vous êtes professeur de
droit public et membre de la commission
des lois et puis avec nous en
visioconférence la porte parole du
ministère de la justice emmanuel masson
bonsoir et bienvenue emmanuel masson je
commence donc avec cet accrochage et
matthieu croissandeau que j'étais en
train de ne pas présenter ça commence
mal cette émission bienvenue mathieu
l'éditorialiste de sens public tous les
lundis mercredi au de vous retrouver
évidemment aller je commence avec cet
accrochage on vient de le voir dans le
sujet précédent entre entre le garde des
sceaux le sénateur est d'ailleurs
philippe bas à ministre attaqué sur son
bilan notamment ce nombre de places de
prison que le gouvernement s'est engagé
à construire est ce que vous trouvez la
halle tac justifié tiens on commence par
un focus mettra der
hoff là vous parlez du nombre des places
de prison et leur avancement lâché j'ai
pas suffisamment d'éléments pour vous
dire mais j'ai le sentiment que parce
que il est ce qu'il est par tout ce
qu'il a pu faire avant de devenir un
ministre parce qu'il est avocat la
critique est effectivement un peu facile
il ya une forme de délégitimation sur
tous les sujets que je trouve un peu
prompte et un peu trop politique alors
qu'effectivement il tente de faire
bouger les lignes avec le petit budget
qui continue même s'il l'a augmentée qui
conquit qui continuent d'être vraiment
fait par rapport à celui de nos voisins
parce que le véritable problème de la
justice et les moyens qu'on lui donne
pour rendre la justice mais sur les
droits de la défense sur je trouve que
ça son projet de loi comporte de belles
avancées c'est vrai que c'est un
millefeuille chaque année on y arrive
avec un nouveau projet et que ce soit
une majorité ou l'autre bon ben voilà
c'est le paquebot conques ont fait
bouger un tout petit peu on est sans
doute loin des standards les plus les
plus appréciables notamment ceux de nos
voisins mais moi je trouve ce qui te
fait du bon travail depuis le temps
finalement il est pas là depuis très
longtemps quatorze mois voilà et il est
où les avocats nous sommes plutôt
contents est assez fier que ce soit un
des nôtres qui porte tout ça c'était du
bois et autres milan on est on élargit
un peu le le faut que les autres du
bilan de 14 mois de d'eric
dupond-moretti côté je suis pas sûr que
tous les avocats soit content pour ma
part à pour avoir discuté avec un
certain non mais enfin effectivement ces
droits de la défense et quelques
avancées dans le projet de loi mais
qu'ils y seront quand même limité c'est
à dire qu'on crée quelques droits pour
quelques-uns et pour nous ça ne va pas
vers l'égalité des citoyens devant la
justice parce que ce sont des droits un
peu à la demande est très limité mais à
part cela disons que pour nous n'est
eric dupond moretti ne part pas du tout
une expertise du terrain
deux des besoins réels de la justice
pour proposer des réformes on est dans
des réformes pour nous de communication
est vraiment l'exemple il ya plusieurs
exemples mais le dernier en date c'est
celui du rappel à la loi qui est
remplacé par le rappel à la loi bis il
ya eu les annonces sur les crédits de
réduction de peine c'est à dire le fait
enfin la manière dont on calcule la fin
de la peine des détenus pour lesquels le
ministre a fait une sortie sur le fait
que des détenus aujourd'hui qu'ils
fassent des efforts ou pas avait la même
peine à faire alors que ce n'est pas le
cas donc on est pour pouvoir dire
ensuite moi je vais mettre cette fin à
ça donc on a vraiment l'impression que
ce ministre est dans la communication
plus que dans l'action et que dans le
fond il n'y a pas d'avancée majeure ni
pour les justiciables ni pour le bon
fonctionnement de la justice bon
emmanuel masson aura l'occasion de
répondre dans un instant je voudrais
simplement entendre le sénateur le rugby
est ce que vous êtes aussi critique que
votre collègue film bah
oui oui je pense parce que vous voyez
l'attitude du garde des sceaux hier
c'est pas une attitude anodine c'est une
aptitude qui a été répété dans
l'hémicycle à de nombreuses reprises est
ce qu'on peut lui reprocher c'est
qu'effectivement
il n'a pas quitté sa robe d'avocat quand
il est rentré dans l'hémicycle c'est à
dire que même dans le cadre de la
défense de ses positions on a toujours
l'impression qu'il en plaidoirie et qui
ne supporte pas la contradiction et ce
quels que soient les bons même un avocat
après c'est moi celui qui se porte le
mieux la contradiction d'écouté c'est
notre métier antenne plaidoirie la
réponse apportée par fois monsieur
dupont meriti à certaines contradictions
à certains amendements c'est à dire
effectivement c'est un texte de portée
très inégale c'est un millefeuille il
n'y a pas de cohérence nous on était
prêt à participer à ces états généraux
de la justice d'ailleurs
l'agora de la justice cette semaine ce
lundi ce lundi organisé par le président
buffet et le président du sénat qu'est
ce qu'on a vu on a vu le corps n'a de la
magistrature des avocats un des
professionnels du droit l'administration
pénitentiaire
avec une certaine forme d'émotion eh
bien on a compris qu'il voulait
participer pleinement à l'amélioration
de la justice au quotidien mais
qu'effectivement et là je vous rejoins
il ya un manque criant de moyens alors
il faut être très honnête oh oui il ya
eu un effort il ya eu un rattrapage du
budget de la justice cette année mais
mais quand on regarde les lois de
règlement sur les dépenses et les
crédits d'investissement des trois
dernières années on se rend compte que
un tiers des crédits n'ont pas été
dépensés donc là où je rejoins madan
parfois il ya beaucoup d'effets
d'annoncé su bâtir ont gonflé le budget
mais si les crédits ne sont pas dépensés
forcément ça général la déception
emmanuel masson bout pas mal de
critiques des éléments de défense aussi
de la part de deux mètres à adder
l'argent qui n'a pas été totalement
dépensé d'aider des propositions un peu
cosmétique je vous n'avez pas employer
ce terme même du web et je le prends
pour moi avec notamment la question du
rappel à la loi qu'est ce que vous
répondez à ces critiques m
entendent rappeler que en cinq ans les
plus prendre en compte l'augmentation
des budgets la vie devant moi j'entends
me dis qu'on a un peu augmenté puisqu'il
faut ressembler à + 8 % des lycéens et
il ya une accusation de 9,1 me paraît en
télé des crédits affectés par exemple il
y avait la même justice n'était pas trop
de la lance sur la justice de forme
sinon t'es où rouler les à l'embauché ou
on a juste été emmenés par la justice de
faire en capacité de procéder à des
embauches les juridictions ont révélé
l'ampleur des juridictions dans un délai
encore nous retrouver les candidats pour
trouver les jurys différents ont trouvé
les candidats pour pour sa justice pour
la nuit dans l'oeuvre de s'ajuster de
profiter et donc je suis en bleu tiens
le surfer avec les pays où on vit elle
est immense et que la communication et
je sais très bien le fait qu'elle
amènera tu ralentis sur la justice de
confronter ce n'est que de la
communication
quand vous n'avez plus de 1000 personnes
du temps recruté en interne en est que
les retours des juridictions sont
extrêmement positifs alors bien sûr ça
c'est dur quand on a que des gens bien
sûr qu'un temps nécessaire pour former
les personnes et qu'elles soient
pleinement opérationnels mais mais c'est
le cas en matière pénale et on en voit
d'ores et déjà des résultats
[Musique]
plusieurs fois dans ce débat pardon d
interrompre katia dubreuil de ne plus de
personnes recrutées en moins d'un an a
déjà j'aimerais savoir comment le
ministre la chancellerie ce que les
retours des juridictions sont positifs
parce que le ministre ne parle pas à
part aux chefs de cours à 36 personnes
en france il ne parle pas aux magistrats
et il n'a aucun contact alors nous nous
voyons nos collègues nous avons des
remontées de tous nos collègues toute
l'année
et nous savons que les juridictions ne
sont pas du tout positive parce que on
rentre on n'embauche pas de magistrat
suffisamment on est toujours très très à
la traîne par rapport à tous nos voisins
tous les pays voisins sur le nombre de
magistrats le nombre de greffiers par
habitant on n'embauche pas de greffiers
non plus et on embauche des contractuels
pour une grosse grosse grosse partie qui
sont des personnels non formés qui
viennent peser en fait sur le
fonctionnement des juridictions et pour
certains qui ont été recrutés dans la
précipitation parce qu'on a dit si on
dépense pas tout de suite l'argent qu'on
a promis oulalalala on va le perdre et
donc on a vu les jours éditions recrutés
sur twitter recruter n'importe comment
33 % en cinq ans dit m c'est la plus
grosse partie de ce budget ça va au
construction de places de prison alors
nous nous faisons partie de ceux qui
disent que la construction de places de
prison ce n'est pas la solution parce
que le portier n'a pas assez oui ça a
sonné on a un désaccord là dessus mais
plus on construit que l'on remplit ce
qu'il faudrait c'est une véritable
politique en matière de peines en
matière d'aménagement des peines en
matière de réforme de la procédure
pénale il ya tout à reconstruire à
remettre à plat effectivement mais là ce
n'est pas ce qui est fait est en tout
cas ce budget ne profite pas
majoritairement à la justice judiciaire
cette année par exemple pour les
juridictions c + 3 % c'est pas plus subi
pour cent alors un mot de réponse des
modèles masson j'espère que le son est
meilleur on a essayé de régler ça on
vous écoute
oui alors le mois mais mal je les
malentendus
[Musique]
vous avez bien compris la gestion on
entend comme dans l'autre bon revenons
à notre côté on va nous dire qu'on fait
leur trou du cul ture de la justice à la
production de l'année moi je peux pas
laisser dire qu'on est arrivé à laval
une nouvelle et longue de 3000 ont pas
le niveau
bac il ya un peu de mal à défendre
on a l'impression qu'on est allé quatre
chaînes payantes il avait fallu on
vient vers vous tout de suite je jouerai
qu'on élargisse un peu cette question de
quand même cette relation un peu
particulière entre le
le garde des sceaux et les sénateurs
parce que quand à calmer joignait c'est
pas la première fois bonsoir quand un
grand centre e le ministre et senna
exactement le ministre n'ait gardé sauf
que depuis un an et deux mois il a déjà
une belle collection effectivement de
passes d'armes dans l'hémicycle a fallu
faire des choix parmi toutes les
références dans les archives de public
sénat alors flashback numéro un au
printemps dernier après la condamnation
en appel de georges tron la sénatrice
socialiste laurence rossignol demande la
révocation de son mandat de maire de
draveil
eh bien elle ne s'en est pas est ce que
ce soit eric dupond moretti qui
répondent ce jour là au nom du
gouvernement écouter me semble que ce
justiciable un formé un pourvoi en
cassation que la décision dès lors n'est
pas définitive et qu'il se débrouille
avec sa conscience ou demandé à
l'exécutif d'intervenir là dedans mais
franchement quelle hérésie je n'aurais
jamais cru que le gouvernement envoie
pour répondre à ma question l'avocat de
georges tron celui qui a traité de
menteuse les victimes pendant tout le
procès et qui continue aujourd'hui les
traiter de menteuse en arguant de la
présomption d'innocence alors que vous
avez été condamné voilà la gauche un qui
n'a pas manqué de monter au créneau à
plusieurs reprises en sur ce thème qu'il
dénonce comme une forme de confusion des
genres entre sa carrière d'avocat et
celle de ministre on se souvient qu on y
était à ce jour là le garde des sceaux
était pour sa part repartie du sénat
très en colère de cette séance des
questions d'actualité au grenier alors
un autre exemple quand à cette fois ci
avec la droite voilà tout à fait y en a
pour tout le monde le point de dépasser
viens c'est davantage similaire à
l'échangeur avec philippe bas c'est la
question un peu du bilan du quinquennat
en l'occurrence du bilan en matière de
lutte contre les féminicides nous sommes
alors en mai dernier quelques jours
après la mort de chahinez qu'ils avaient
été brûlés vifs ce par son mari est donc
le ton et ben il est montré très très
fort ce jour-là et attention à vos
oreilles
monsieur le premier ministre
tous les meurtres de femmes ne peuvent
pas être évité celui là aurait dû l'être
si vous vous étiez donner les moyens
d'appliquer des lois que vous avez
vous-même voter ma question est donc
simple n'avez vous pas honte d'une telle
inefficacité de votre politique ce qui
parfois me fait honte
c'est l'exploitation
c'est l'exploitation cynique
cynique et obscène d'une situation que
nous avons tous à déplorer
avec beaucoup d'émotion
j'ai entièrement vous répondez dans le
respect voilà et donc on a vu un ces
échanges alors vous m'avez un piqué ma
chute monsieur rue d'ulm et ce avec
certains sénateurs nous disent que les
vins il n'a pas forcément réussi à
sortir de son de sa robe d'avocate pour
véritablement rentrer dans son costume
des ministres et merci beaucoup quentin
mais c'est une vraie question à laquelle
on peut répondre notamment la question
de dut alors je vais dire conflit
d'intérêts en tout cas où confusion des
genres ça voudrait dire quoi se dire
qu'un avocat ne peut pas devenir
ministre de la justice puisqu'il a
forcément eu des affaires précédemment
c'est comment vous réagissez à ça vous
dit
je ne cèderai pas sur votre chaîne
c'était une chaîne du service public il
ya quelques semaines abbas est un
magnifique reportage sur badinter et
lorsque badinter porte quitte sa robe
d'avocat et portent sûr que tout le
monde aujourd'hui salue comme un grand
moment de notre république l'abolition
de la peine de mort on entre là dans le
dans les aviez ces échanges la sévère
que nécessairement le met en cause comme
étant un avocat qui avait défendu des
assassins d'enfants etc et donc on le
déconsidérer à chaque fois moi je trouve
ça moi aussi obscène de prendre un cas
particulier pour stigmatiser une
politique sur lequel un ministre qui
vient là puis 14 mois honnêtement
d'arena n'a donc là c'est une politique
c'est sans doute parce qu'on est avocat
et que par nature on déplaît mais mais
mais je vois énormément de ressemblance
avec la situation de banat terre ce qui
était intéressant d'ailleurs je termine
dans ce reportage c'est qu'on s'aperçoit
quatre ans après tout le monde le loup
tout le monde loue son courage etc il
faut se souvenir comment il était mise
en cause parce qu'il avait été avocate
parce qu'il avait été défenseur sur la
cour d'assises donc ça devrait prêter à
réfléchir à ce qu'il attaque peut-être
moi je trouve un peu bassement stefano
régulier à ta copine c'est les termes
qui viennent d'être employé ou renault
et le les germes du garde des sceaux
fondamentalement nous ne sommes pas
contre
le métier d'avocat jauge rappel jusqu'à
beaucoup de sénateurs dans toute famille
poétique dans le métier
de fond la pratique et le droit avocat
ou autre mais bien qu'ils s'en
souviennent quelquefois pardon j'ai déjà
dit ce serait bien qu'ils s'en
souviennent quelques noms mais il s'en
souvient le voyez je vais vous citer un
exemple parce que le secret
professionnel
l'extension du secret professionnel de
l'avocat quand il s'agit de défendre la
pro cette profession notamment sur
l'indivisibilité de ce secret
professionnel de ne pas faire des
catégories par rapport à la matière du
droit un droit fiscal ou autre on est là
aussi pour défendre ce métier ne ne ne
faisons pas le procès en dix ans c'est
par rapport à sa profession d'avocat
c'est juste que je pense sincèrement que
l'attitude en séance publique n'est pas
une attitude qui soit cohérente avec la
fonction de ministre d'ailleurs vous
savez le président larcher
quand il rappelle un ministre à l'ordre
c'est exceptionnel vous pouvez aller
voir toutes les archives rarement le
président larcher père se permet
d'interrompre un mini pour le remède et
lui faire un rappel au règlement alors
ça pose la question finalement de de
l'attitude du style dupond moretti
on peut lui reprocher son style à la
eric dupond moretti en plus reprochés sa
méthode d'une certaine façon et c'est
vrai qu'il ya une absence de
concertation avec les syndicats parce
que le dialogue est rompu on peut lui
reprocher aussi ses choix ou critiquer
ses choix mais on peut pas dire que
c'est un ministre car rien fait enfin
moi ça me paraît en observateur très
très exagérées il a été importé 19 texte
de loi les moyens ont quand même
augmenté il faut dire s'est passé on
peut dire c'est que du rattrapage mais
ça a augmenté comme jamais cela n'avait
augmenté depuis une vingtaine d'années
une trentaine d'heures il faut remonter
je crois dominique perben qui avait
obtenu une augmentation de 7 ou 8% quand
il était garde des sceaux il ya les
places de prison vous en parliez il y en
a sept mille côté construite alors après
le ministère la justice dit qu'il y en a
huit mille qui vont l'être et qui sont
budgétés on peut dire c'est du pipeau ça
sera pas avant tout cas voilà il ya
quand même des choses et les emploi
d'assistant contractuels pour à la fois
les juridictions au pénal ici il on peut
dire c'est d'aider des contractuels
justement et parle pas des vrais
magistrats mais ils sont là enfin voilà
il ya quand même des choses qui ont été
faites ça ça me paraît exagéré de dire
qui et qui n'a rien fait cathy dubois
est ce que c'est un garde des sceaux qui
est hostile aux magistrats
en fait c'est pas tellement comme ça que
la question se pose il était avocat il
avait son style comme avocat moi je
trouve que les questions style c'est pas
tellement vraiment le problème où la
question la question on a parfois
l'impression que jean dans notre
perception via les souvenirs de de
l'avocat non je pense pas en tout cas du
côté de la sni syndicat de la
magistrature qu'on puisse dire ça ce qui
est sûr c'est que quand on est avocat on
endosse un costume dans lequel on défend
les intérêts d'un client et plus
largement on quand on est avocat il ya
une éthique de l'avocat qui est très
belle enfin voilà que je crois les
magistrats peuvent avoir en partage
aussi sur le fait qu'on défend un homme
qu'on fasse tout pour qu'on aille
jusqu'au bout pour défendre un homme et
tout ça est très bien quand on devient
ministre on défend l'intérêt général et
c'est là où les magistrats ont eu un
problème avec ce ministre 1 c'est pas
parce qu'il était avocat avant
effectivement comme vous le disiez je
crois pas que les magistrats étaient
outrés par exemple par
les actions du ministre badinter à
l'époque là ce qui s'est passé et la
rupture qui existent entre les
magistrats et eric dupond moretti c'est
parce que effectivement il ya ces
questions conflits d'intérêts il ya ces
questions d' atteintes portées à
l'indépendance de la justice à travers
quand même une vendetta en tout cas ce
que nous on analyse comme une vendetta
par rapport au parquet national
financiers et donc c'est quelque chose
qui pose question parce que quand on
devient ministre on doit oeuvrer pour
l'intérêt général et pas pour des
intérêts particuliers c'est ça qui pour
nous et peut constituer un souci ce
n'est pas effectivement le style plus ou
moins grande gueule entre guillemets et
c'est qui ça c'est en partie vrai mais
ce qu'est ce que l'exemple de mai quand
un dialogue que ça vous choque que ce
soit lui qui répondent au sénat sur la
sphère georges tron pas et je pense
qu'effectivement
il faut faire attention par rapport à
ces questions de conflits d'intérêts il
faut donner il faut pas donner
l'impression qu'ils puissent y avoir des
passe droits pour certains ou que
certains peuvent être favorisée par ap
par la position de leurs avants de
l'ancien avocat et une nouvelle fonction
le nouvel avocat ce n'est pas à mon sens
ce n'est pas normal que ce soit le mieux
l'ancien avocat qui répondent comme
ministre à cette question il ya un
certain nombre de choses comme ça qui
sont sont répétées depuis plusieurs mois
et qui montrent qu'effectivement ce
n'est pas tellement dans le logiciel du
ministre que de raisonner en terme
en tout cas de ou au minimum en
apparence eux
par rapport à la question de l'égalité
des citoyens et la question d'intérêt
général je vous signale jusque emmanuel
masson on peut plus retourner vers elle
puisqu' on a vraiment un problème de son
qui connaissent pas réglé donc voilà on
l'aura entendu au début de notre débat
et il aura pu porter la parole du
ministère et aussi de du ministre m
adhère le le style dray sur le style de
d'eric dupond mérite maurice qui faisait
sa force
d'avocats c'est notamment le pouvoir des
mots c'est aussi un atout en politique
ça je trouvais qu'il s'en sert qui s'en
sert bien vous avez pensé que je me
réfère toujours à l'histoire mais mais
mais quand on voit alors y'a pas bien
peu de films mais quand on lit les
échanges à la chambre sous la troisième
république
c'est vrai que c'était un public qu'il y
avait plus d'avocats encore
qu'aujourd'hui mais quelle vie qu'elles
échangent quel magnifique milieu de
démocratique des changes il faudrait
tout soit policiers avec des langues de
bois et des médailles la communication
prémâché et qu'on livrerait en lisant
son truc il n'y a rien de plus triste
que les séances à à l'assemblée
nationale du mercredi lorsque tout le
monde lit son papier bien préparée par
son parti l'a enfin il ya un petit peu
de vie eh bien écoutez
ça donne ça donne à présent larcher qui
le reprend 1 min ça vous dit que c'est
rare donc ça me trouvais ça dommage
choix politiques je ne sais pas pourquoi
ou comme moi sur ce que j'ai vu j'ai
rien vu des d'épouvantables
non mais des exemples la démocratie
c'est aussi aussi la vie puis c'est
cesser donc moi moi le d'ailleurs je
trouve c'est ma dernière observation
mais mais que lui reprochez la forme
c'est que finalement on est assez court
sur le fond ah ben là c'est moi qui
décide de faire le fond la forme le fond
mais on va rester quand même un peu sur
sur le sur le bilan et puis alors cette
histoire de enfin voilà devenus mous et
c'est ce que j'ai employé dans mes
titres mathieu est ce que vous diriez
avec votre regard d'éditorialistes qu'il
a gagné ses galons d'un politique
finalement pas d'abord je dirais que
c'était pas gagné souvenez vous quand il
arrivait même dans la macro ni les gens
craignaient qu'il fasse son hulot c'est
à dire que ce soit quelqu'un de la
société civile qui arrive qui finissent
par claquer la porte parce que la greffe
ne prendrai pas à cause des codes et
puis surtout à cause de son tempérament
qu'on connaît d'autant que ses débuts
ont été chahutées il faut le rappeler il
a été accueilli au bazooka par certains
syndicats de magistrats alors ce n'est
pas vous mais de ceux qui avaient parlé
de déclaration de guerre ça c'était du
sms il a été pris tout de suite leur
espèce de la polémique et intra
gouvernementale sur lens hommage mans où
s'est opposé à gérald darmanin et
pourtant quatorze mois plus tard faut
reconnaître qu'il a connu des coups durs
mais toujours en poste et puis s'est
fait quand même sa place sur le sur la
scène politique avec une forme de
résilience des succès et des revers ou
alors des succès on commence par les
points positifs mais à quoi on juge
qu'un homme est devenu un homme
politique sur sa capacité à peser sur sa
capacité à agir sa capacité à peser on a
dit ah quand même peser sur les
arbitrages budgétaires il a eu un début
de giro sur sa capacité à agir encore
une fois on peut contester les lois
qu'il a portée mais il en a porté et
puis après il ya aux angles sa montre en
tout cas qu'il n'était pas venu faire de
la figuration après il ya la face
émergée de l'iceberg qui sont son sens
de la formule ces petites phrases
assassines on les a vu son style il ya
aussi la face immergée qui est un autre
eric dupond moretti avec une capacité à
faire atterrir des textes qui sont
parfois compliquées souvenez-vous le
texte de loi sur sur le séparatisme qui
venait juste après le texte de loi sur
sécurité globale la majorité étaient
chauffés à blanc il a fini par sur les
des textes qui était compliqué sur la
haine en ligne par exemple vous sonnez
la loi via cam était en toc et de la sas
est plutôt passée sur le code de la
justice pénale des mineurs s'étaient
alors s'était lancé avant lui s'étaient
fa lui mais lors de lens 42 45 point
d'en parler mais ça finit par atterrir
au cil puis sa loi c'est vrai que c'est
un millefeuille mais voilà il y alors
après on peut c'est je ne dis pas que
c'est à wau sa succession mais ça
démontre en tout cas une capacité que ce
qu'on craignait que ce soit une espèce
de d'antagonistes permanent et il a été
capable de montrer ça pour les points
positifs de juste dans les propositions
s'il ya une forme il assume ses
convictions quand la justice a été très
très mise en cause notamment par les
syndicats de policiers alors il est allé
vomir et c'était son rôle il est garde
des sceaux mais y'a pas grand monde pour
y aller y compris pour prendre des
positions qui étaient très très
minoritaire dans l'opinion
après les échecs en tant qu'homme
politique moi j'en vois bien évidemment
auquel tout le monde pense c'est l'échec
électoral le missile dupond moretti qui
devait à la fois atomisé le
rassemblement national et xavier
bertrand il perdu ses deux cibles on
rappelle que il était tête de liste dans
le département du pas de calais si ma
mémoire est bonne et la une à la liste
s'est même pas qualifié en tout cas la
liste aux régionales ce n'est pas
qualifié pour le pour le second tour son
second échec plus subjectif à mes yeux
c'est est ce qu'il est parvenu à
incarner l'ailé gauche de la majorité
c'est également au départ au moment de
sa nomination c'est à la fois un coup
médiatique parce qu'on prenait plus les
deux avocats et puis y avait l'idée de
nommer eric dupond moretti qui est un
ancien soutien de martine aubry plutôt
étiqueté à gauche pour peut-être
rééquilibrer un gouvernement qui était
jugée trop à droite bella pour le pour
le coup la réponse est non peut-être
l'at-il fait dans son ministère sur
certaines valeurs mais en tout cas sur
l'échiquier politique national et à
l'intérieur du gouvernement il n'a pas
encore peser sur des choix pour faire
entendre cette sensibilité katia
dubreuil est ce que c'est une carte
politique dans le dans le jeu du
président de la république eric dupond
moretti oui enfin c'est sûr que par
rapport au choix d'eric dupond-moretti
on pense quand même quand on voit parce
que on n'a pas la même analyse on vous
parlait tous les tests qu'il a fait
adopter un certain nombre qui était déjà
lancée sur aucun motif arrive il y en a
un certain nombre qui sont des textes du
ministère de l'intérieur et de la
justice dans lesquels finalement c'est
plutôt l'intérieur soyons clairs qui
drive est d'ailleurs sur le fond en fait
ce qu'on ce qu'on constate et là pour le
coup de nombreux avocats sont d'accord
avec ça ce sont des renoncements par
rapport à des principes que l'avocat
dupond-moretti défend des
genre avant de devenir ministre et qui
sur lesquels il a totalement lâché prise
la cour d'assisses la cour d'assises les
droits des détenus et c'est eric star à
tous les discours qu'ils pouvaient avoir
auparavant il a totalement mis de côté
ses convictions pour rentrer dans
effectivement pour nous un un discours
général du gouvernement qui est un
discours assez sécuritaire qui est
portée principalement par le ministère
de l'intérieur et donc ce sont des
textes qui sont en réalité des textes du
ministère de l'intérieur soyons très
clairs
l'homme de gauche s'est droitisée
ne connaissait pas salir autres vous
dire ce que je peux vous dire c'est
qu'il défende est des valeurs qui sont
importantes pour la justice en tant
qu'avocat le respect de la présomption
d'innocence le respect de la justice de
la cour d'assises le fait que la prison
n'était il fallait qu'il y ait des
conditions dans prison qui soit digne et
caetera et que on entend ce même
ministre arrivé pour nous dire
aujourd'hui ça va pas les aménagements
de peine on ne devrait pas laisser les
ai tenus sortir s'ils ne font pas
d'efforts et avec ce discours
extrêmement voilà un discours qui sans
c'est peut-être plaire à l'opinion et
qui cadre très bien avec ce qu'on attend
de lui dans la perspective de la de la
campagne électorale donc notre sentiment
c'est plutôt des textes qui colle à une
comme que des textes qui colle à des
besoins de la justice comme je le disais
tout à l'heure et donc en réalité oui
pour nous il a été choisi surtout parce
qu'il pouvait apporter quelque chose au
gouvernement un peu de peps la carte
anti marine le pen peut être et en même
temps
avec un homme qui à la fois une image
proche des personnes parce qu'il était
avocat qu'il était connu et en même
temps une qui pouvait comme il était
avocat donner l'impression qu'ils
avaient une colonne vertébrale en termes
de respect de l'état de droit des droits
l'homme etc mais sauf que la colonne
vertébrale nous on la voit plus trop
aujourd'hui est ce qui la base il a
divulgué une partie de ces conventions
bien sûr qu'il ya sur certaines
questions sur laquelle on est évidemment
d'accord surtout quand on exerce en
matière pénale mais mais mais il faut
être réaliste souci jusqu'à quel point
il peut porter les choses sont forcément
elle soit goni parlera par toute la
partie qui ne supporte pas donc donc il
ya des arbitrages qui sont sans doute
pas les siens moi je trouve qu'il fait
ça très courageusement et dans la mesure
de ses moyens ce qui sont ceux de la
chancellerie et on sait que entre bercy
et et mouvaux et il reste peu de place
c'est une constante d'un autre dans
notre république il faut s'appeler
badinter ou auto bira pour arriver à
pousser ça ce que j'espère mais il ne
fait que commencer c'est qu'il va y
arriver et je trouve que les signes
qu'il donne sont bons moi je dis ça de
ma lanterne avec lui ce pas un
observateur de tout ce qui se fait et
sur la présomption d'innocence il se
trouve que je participe aux travaux de
la banking où nous allons voir des
propositions très audacieuse pour pour
la protéger
renoncer oui mais des fois
on a été entendus par cette commission
il ya une dimension également ce et puis
c'est pas banal c'est un
un mini zoo la justice qui est mise en
examen bonjour est qu'on parle de ça
aussi maintenant c'était le président
sonné me sens
je vais dire présumé prise illégale
d'intérêts c'est ce que j'avais prévu 19
juillet dernier on va écouter une dupond
moretti
je suis plus que jamais déterminé à être
pleinement ministre de la justice rien
n'entamera ma détermination
je suis extrêmement serein ma légitimité
je la tiens du président de la
république et du premier ministre et
j'ai reçu un certain nombre de soutiens
même de l'opposition des soutiens
extrêmement nombreux je veux vous dire
monsieur en tant que justiciable j'ai
comme tout le monde des avocats qui
feront valoir mes droits et en tant que
ministre je suis à 100% dans la tâche
qui est la mienne
stéphane le rudulier présomption
d'innocence c'est normal qu'il reste en
poste
oui franchement c'est pas c'est pas là
dessus clairement ça le regarde c'est
par rapport à sa liberté de conscience
ce qu'il est ce qu'il explique à la
rigueur je peux le partager avec
d'autres jurisprudence a
prévu de se mettre en retrait chacun
agit en son âme et conscience ces jeux
là là dessus je serai pas attaqué il ya
une présomption d'innocence c'est
l'homme en tant que tel il ya l'homme
politique et je préfère me concentrer
sur ses actions sur son style dans
l'hémicycle à travers ses interventions
que sur éventuellement ses affaires avec
la justice on se souvient qu'un éphémère
garde des sceaux qui s'appelait françois
bayroux qui lui a démissionné
précisément parce qu'ils étaient mises
en cause
non mais en même temps j'avais des mises
en cause mais je veux dire ça le regarde
je suis pas en train de défendre dupond
moretti là c'est le plan totalement
judiciaire qui regardent nullement à mon
avis le politique que je suis vous
pensez pas que ça le fragilise
politiquement
ça l'a sans doute fragilisé quelques
jours et puis je pense que plus personne
maintenant ne me remets en cause sa
fonction et j'entends pas dans
l'hémicycle en dix ans il était mis en
examen il n'est pas légitime pour porter
tel ou tel projet de loin savez moi je
préfère discuter du bilan de la création
de prison puisque tout à l'heure j'ai
entendu des chiffres qui ne sont pas
véritablement la réalité que de savoir
si oui ou non dupond moretti aurait dû
rester à son poste par rapport à sa mise
en examen on va y venir un mot là-dessus
mathieu l'epo ces questions d'époque en
fait finalement c'est vrai
évolution de la jurisprudence il faut le
reconnaître je le disais fonctionner ou
telle mise en cause parce qu'elle était
totalement injuste parce qu'elle était
totale on t'a vu sur tout cas c'était
devenu un usage donc lu l'échangé
pardonnez-moi mais l'instrumentalisation
qui en a résulté dans les affaires
politiques auquel tout le monde pense il
suffit de déposer une plainte de
provoquer de mise en examen pour
désarçonner il y avait une invitation du
jeu
ça ne m'a pas échappé ce que je veux
dire c'est que vous savez très bien que
il ya trop de faculté offerte par ce que
cette jurisprudence qui tient
effectivement au gouvernement balladur
un juge de devenir s'inviter dans le jeu
politique je disais juste que cette
chance de danser elle évolue à l'échelle
mois quinquennat
puisque le cac à mâcon des mêmes
faits dont s'agit si vous voulez le
vidame ans le seul bémol que je pourrais
mettre c'est par rapport au climat de
défiance qu'on ne concitoyens par
rapport à la classe politique oui c'est
pour sa sagesse est cette loi du zajal
est propice à la dure ça je pense que le
gouvernement et le président la
république a pesé le pour et le contre
mais après c'est une question
personnelle de conscience il a décidé de
rester c'est qu'il se considère comme il
nous sommes innocents bah voilà oui je
pense qu'effectivement la présomption
d'innocence joue donc c'est un principe
qui peut mener a aussi considéré qu'on
peut rester ou ne pas rester c'est pas
la question en nous ce qui nous a par
contre poser choqué institutionnellement
c'est la manière dont le gouvernement et
le président de la république et le
premier ministre ont apporté leur
soutien à eric dupond-moretti non pas en
dix ans
cet homme est présumé innocent donc il
restera au gouvernement mais en dix ans
c'est rien du tout c'est fait donc il
reste au gouvernement là c'est tout à
fait autre chose parce que ces faits à
les supposer établies ne serait pas rien
du tout comme être une prise illégale
d'intérêts c'est pas rien du tout et ce
ne sont ni le président de la république
ni le premier ministre qui sont aptes à
pouvoir juger en théorie n'ont pas accès
à la procédure du moins je l'espère si
le ministre a commis ces faits ou non
donc le problème c'est dans cette
affaire hier dont on est venu jeter le
discrédit sur la décision qui a été
prise par la cjr en expliquant que
finalement une fois de plus c'était des
juges qui venaient faire n'importe quoi
et que la ministre pouvait bien rester
ça c'est tout à fait différent d'un
discours sur la présomption d'innocence
qu'on peut faire tout à fait entendre et
ça ça pose un grand problème dans une
démocratie dans une république de voir
que pour défendre un ministre le
président de la république qui est par
ailleurs dans la constitution garant de
l'indépendance de la justice il ya en
quelque sorte critique et j'étais un peu
le discrédit sur une décision de justice
alors j'aimerais qu'on revienne sur
cette loi sur la confiance dans la
justice avec vous nous avez parlé de
l'agora qui a été organisé au sénat ce
lundi une étude qui a été commandé par
le sénat auprès de csa hui search avec
vous donne quelques résultats
53% des français qui disent ne pas avoir
confiance en la justice et puis sur
l'image voile et les adjectifs les
qualificatifs qui ressorte élite lanta
93% opaque 69% lac 6 68% éloigné
67%
sadi l'urgence de cette loi d'une
certaine façon c'est le sénateur
l'urgence de cette loi mais encore une
fois cette loi elle est incomplète je
vous rappelle simplement que à
l'assemblée nationale ouah on va étudier
un nouveau texte sur la justice d'ici
quelques jours donc c'est là où et c'est
une des propositions fortes de l'agora
c'est de dire arrêtons la prolifération
législatif et réglementaire qui est un
peu mortifère pour l'institution bouquin
c'est ce que dit c'est ce que disait on
va l'écouter tout de suite je vous
redonne la parole juste après françois
colas le procureur général près la cour
de cassation de cassation écoute alors
effectivement je vous rejoins dans la
logique effectivement rationalisation
sortir de l'empilage sortir de ce qu'on
pourrait qualifier de phénomène de 'fait
diversification de la loi pénale ou un
fait divers intervient on prend une loi
pour essayer de corriger évitez aussi
ces phénomènes de simplification qui
n'en sont plus je ne compte plus les
lois de simplification qui sont
intervenus dans une intention très
louable depuis quelques années sur le
terrain quand on simplifie tous les deux
ans on complique la tâche des enquêteurs
je pense qu'on est devant une procédure
pénale qui appelle des réponses de fond
une procédure pénale qui est à bout je
dis bien à bout qui ne satisfait plus
personne ni les magistrats ni les
enquêteurs ni les avocats le constat il
est il est assez catastrophique dans la
dans la voie de conséquence orient
maintenant il faut arrêter de d'empiler
les lois donc c'est quoi la solution la
solution c'est de faire un diagnostic
cohérent je peux plusieurs mois écouter
l'ensemble des acteurs et faire une
véritable et unique réforme de la
justice est pas un empilage de loin
c'est ça le problème le véritable
problème je vois mon partenaire qui
n'est pas du tout mais le véritable
problème c'est qu'on prend pas le temps
et là je rejoins
monsieur - se procurant moulin
effectivement et ça ça fait des lustres
la gauche comme la droite l'a pratiqué
dès qu'un fait divers on répond par ce
fait divers à travers une loi et
attendent un souci de cohérence globale
des textes quand nicolas sarkozy était
ministre de l'intérieur il savait très
bien faire mais que ce soit nicolas
sarkozy françois hollande emmanuel
macron c'est la même chose et une
prolifération l'initiative le code de
procédure pénale a été multiplié par
huit en 30 ans souvent la demande via
position et qu'elle soit qu'est ce que
vous comptez
tacle nicolas sarkozy comme une frise
du code de procédure pénale donc évaluer
faire une procédure d'évaluation et
derrière porter une véritable réforme
l'agora ses seize propositions et parmi
la première des propositions ce
véritable c'est véritablement cette
évaluation qui permettra après en
concertation avec les acteurs également
de proposer un cadre législatif et un
cadre réglementaire pour véritablement
réformer la lenteur de la jirs niveau là
dessus une allende et la lenteur ferait
elle s'est accentuée les cinq dernières
années c'est un processus irréversible
la lenteur il ya pas que des moyens
humains on peut mettre des moyens mais
si on a un code de procédure pénale qui
a mené la confusion basile ader oui mais
moi c'est moi ça fait
35 ans que ses avocats j'ai dû avoir une
réforme de procédure pénale de pénal
depuis tous les ans et à chaque fois on
arrive maintenant alors maintenant c'est
nous qui a été fait avant c'est
n'importe quoi au fait on reprend tout à
zéro une grande évaluation on va là il
ya deux questions qui sont pour moi la
nique aux sans abri c'est une conclusion
rien les moyens je l'aï déjà dit c'est
des moyens des moyens des moyens ici à
plus de juge plus d'enquêteurs qui sont
mieux formés qui ont plusieurs des
outils qui ont plu au matériel on ira
beaucoup plus vite prendre à une
meilleure justice et ça c'est juste un
chèque la deuxième c'est qu'on a une
procédure pénale qui est hybride mais on
est entré en guerre entre une procédure
inquisitoire qu'il n'y est quel fruit
notre histoire et une procédure
accusatoire laquelle nous emmène la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme et donc
aujourd'hui on ne sait plus siens dhr au
silence un droit de se taire un droit de
dire non la vérité si un juge
d'instruction encore une utilité si un
enquêteur doit faire des choses avec un
juge qu' on est aujourd'hui dans un état
d'incertitude qui dure depuis longtemps
parce qu'on est au milieu du gué et sa
suite une réponse de techniciens merci
beaucoup merci à tous les trois d'avoir
participé à ce débat